hello welcome back to GameSpot's
continuing coverage of e3 2015 we are
live in the West Hall right here in the
LACC and Los Angeles California and I'm
drawing lighted tibi time and awaits how
you doing sir how are you I'm doing
great you're wearing a rainbow 6 siege
shirt that probably means you're on here
to talk about rainbow 6 siege a little
bit yes I am first question right at the
gate where's ding chavez pink chavez
what are you doing to me man I'm
old-school rainbow six fun where's my
boy thing can I pay myself thing well we
are we don't have ding but we do have a
lot of stuff for your room Oh rainbow
six ven terra terra watches back all
right tell me about Appa well terrorist
on his back it's gonna have four modes
three modes of you as an attacker and
one motors we're even as a defender
we're gonna have in one of those modes
is terror hunt classic which is the one
you know and love just breaking in
eliminating all the terrorists what you
saw yesterday is a new mode called
disarm bombs you get to break in disarm
two bombs and we have made the most
challenging AI yet in the rainbow six
game excellent yeah the presentation
yesterday was was very bombastic I think
you guys have done a good job of trying
to sort of communicate what this game is
to people through the beta's to coverage
game sites have been doing and at times
it feels like this is because rainbow
six is a game that can be very like the
old rainbow six are very methodical and
planning based but then also when you
think about vegas or you think about
what happens when when [ __ ] hits the fan
it kind of gets crazy how difficult is
it to sort of balance those two worlds
like a sort of a slow pace but then when
it when it kicks it really gets frenetic
well we wanted to have an ebb and flow
so we wanted players to spawn and doing
a tense situation where I tense mission
or attention match on PvP and then like
being in a tense match people should
start talking right but then we have you
know it's very quiet in this and it's
then we had yesterday and then the hands
on but then you notice as soon as you
kind of break into the consulate in to
where you know into the Tarot stronghold
things just spiked really quick and you
have to just you know you have to move
you have to you have to talk if the
communicate you have to move tactically
a bit you know otherwise it'll be a bit
punish so it's this ebb and flow of you
know silence and then a crescendo and
then and then it goes back down and then
once you play
defuser hear this the tension rises
right again and the pteros come right
back at you so we've done it really I
think we've experimented a lot we
iterate a lot i find this ebb and flow
of tension silence attention sea note as
crescendo right I was on PvP and now at
erawan yeah so PvP obviously was
allowable while we've seen over the past
couple of months so you telling me as
everyone else involved in the terrorist
side of this Rai combatants yes so we
have it's it's a one captain for other
teammates and everybody else here is all
AI is the set of difference each time
you load up like because one of the cool
things about siege is there are so many
different ways for the defenders for the
terrorists to sort of set up there at
their their barriers and their
parameters and stuff so each time you do
this does it change yeah so we all our
design decisions in making the new
terrorist son has been about
replayability like in players interact
with the sandbox or now the AI is going
to interact with the sandbox as well so
we basically every single time you load
up a match of terror hunt or a mission
in terror hunt we it could be two
versions of a map so day or night three
difficulties but they also each that we
have an AI strategy manager that sets
certain things in certain traps every
single time you load up into two ND
terrace on there's a new puzzle for
players to solve we wanted wanted to
make it make it so that you never had
the same experience twice terrorists on
yeah and one thing I'm delighted I got
you guys on the stage because when i was
watching I was freaking out but this is
probably completely wrong but is this
the same level from the first rainbow
six game the the front of the like
ambassador's house it looks like almost
identical well we were definitely
inspired by previous game ever since the
get-go we haven't been quiet about that
so in making a kind of a very rainbow
fantasy like unveiling and billing
terrorists on what you want to kind of
keep it classic so you're in a consulate
here and you're moving through and yeah
we and yet it's similar kind of on
purpose yeah I like it the front
definitely gave me that nice bit of
reminiscing there and the GIGN guy here
getting helped up in terms of difficulty
one of the issues I guess with these
games is that there's so many different
pieces mechanisms that a player has to
learn and trying to teach somebody had
to play
the siege levels you're showing and in
the debate is and the we've covered
that's kind of an easy enough concept to
understand there's a defending team in
an attacking team and you kind of have
to you know one team's role is and is
the way it is in the class to sort of
fit into that and having multiple types
of these modes means that every single
time you've any mode you have to teach
the players something new again and in
something like this where you're you're
trying to teach for people or so to like
work together against an AI and what are
the challenges development wise to try
and like communicate that stuff so you
should get smoked communication right
it's about science and feedback let me
let player know what's going on in the
mode what's kind of going on for all the
players going to get into on a very
surface level right but again because of
the fact that we did is a very tense
situation we found it as because it's a
very tense game and no respawn certainly
helps that I lethality big canister like
fine I like I'm so interested in this
game so players actually communicate a
lot more really yeah because the fact
that they just start talking whenever
it's a tense situation like it's same
people watch horror movies make it a
certain like talking about what yeah
right so we found it's a very cool
domino effect that happens here and
additionally we want to make it all
about the player experience here in
siege as across all the Mo's all of our
the players progression as they progress
you can progress and recruit operators
mmm regardless of any mode you want to
do so that helps us in the teaching
component of if you're a PvP player
you'll learn PvP by playing PvP yeah
you're a PVE player you're learn and
you're like signal and you'll progress
and learn PvE by playing it right we're
very hands-on player centric game so the
more you play the more you play the
surface level is very important but then
as you discover the depth it's all about
playing more and being interested in
seeing all the different nuances you can
do another interesting thing about siege
when I was first playing the various
autism was that it was almost like
people didn't realize you could just
blow through walls like you had to
communicate that to the player that
actually this isn't like a normal
first-person shooter you don't have to
stay within the boundaries of the
building you can sort of make your own
path through it what's up in like for
you guys watching players kind of get to
grips with that concept what we see
players kind of are there they just kind
of seek things out they can test things
out and as soon as they test something
out going on this might not work and it
does all of a sub
oh wow as any experiment constantly like
players experimenting inside of this
little playground sandbox we made this
is the most entertaining part of what of
for us as developers in the closed alpha
we saw so many amazing things we learned
a lot yeah streamlining and teach them a
bit more but just in general the
experimentation if players go through
and the creativity the things they come
up with both the defense and attack I
think it's awesome and that we knew that
that's that's exactly what we wanted
from them and that's what they want from
us now so they get used to it thanks day
they like a lot more so we're gonna keep
that there yeah presumably as well when
you've got these complex game modes that
obviously take a lot of resources from
you guys to make sure that they play
well and inside of these these these are
the levels play well inside of these
various game modes and does that limit
the amount of levels than you then get
to create like how many levels can we
expect to play in Rainbow six siege you
will have 11 and there's two variations
of each one this day and night so what
kind of changes things up in terms of
visibility reactions that people have
both on a both the AI and the players so
it was all about iteration for us we had
to iterate constantly otherwise you know
it was going to be like a very strange
experience wanted to be very consistent
every single map has just as much
creativity as a previous one the sizes
may change but we wanted to be very it
was very important for us that we nail
that there was so much fun and it was
still that awesome sandbox and all 11
maps so we're still iterating here as we
as we push forward to launch but uh well
you know players will help a lot with
that I have helped a lot with that with
the beta with the part with the alpha so
yeah it's it's elbow iteration it's all
about just constantly you know making it
in testing and testing and testing
that's helped us so much awesomenauts
question for you Andrew and that the
Vegas games were super fun multiplayer
wise like single-player was excellent
multiplayer was really good I always had
a bunch of like core friends who were
really into that and when you think of
it rainbow six you think of everybody
succeed are you stepping into the sort
of eSports aspect of it because it's
sort of a difficult area to really stand
your ground kind of strike go seems to
be doing making a pretty good go of it
now so are you with all this multiplayer
stop you trying to get into the eSports
light or are you making this for you
know a couple of dudes and girls to play
co-op with their buddies for us our goal
is to make a competitive tactical
shooter we want rainbow to be a
competitive tactical shooter about
player creativity
that's our mission right now I mean
after October 13th players want to take
things into a different direction and
community wants to take in direction
will follow the community yeah I mean
we've been very vocal about that with
the feedback we've got the closed alpha
and tweaking the game based on so much
feedback so again we'll follow the
community wherever they want us to go so
they want to go to that direction of the
direction we're on board awesome and
when can we expect to play it on what
platforms your play play it octobre 13
on xbox one ps4 and PC this year video
games coming out this year Andruw it's
like you so much free time really
appreciate it and best of luck finishing
up it looks like a great game can we see
more of it and thank you for watching my
little part here on the game spots age
I'm done for today but the one and only
loose James game is ready to come up
here and do a much better job than me so
make sure you stay tuned right here on
gamespot com